foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to this prototyping
tutorial where we'll show you how to
create this beautiful animated bottom
navigation in figma trust me it's a lot
simpler than you might think we've also
prepared source files for you which you
can download from the link in the
description below this video and use in
your own projects
ready great let's Dive Right In First
we'll want to take a quick look at our
phone frame screen to get a sense of its
width perfect it's coming in at 375
pixels which is what we want now let's
navigate over to our shape tools
specifically the rectangle to carve out
the foundation of our navigation bar
we'll go ahead and create a rectangle
with a width of 375 pixels to match our
screen for the height let's give it 76
pixels this should provide a great
balance of space for our icons without
overwhelming the design next we'll opt
for a dark gray color for our rectangle
this subtle Hue will ensure consistency
and integration with the overall dark
aesthetic of the app
now let's transition into the next phase
of our design creating a clickable area
for our icons or tabs
foreign
to ensure that their touch friendly
we'll set Dimensions at 78 pixels in
width and 40 pixels in height we should
be aiming for at least 44 pixels for
optimal usability but for the purposes
of this tutorial we'll stick with 40.
after removing the fill let's paste our
home icon into our first tab
we'll align it right in the middle and
create a duplicate
we then copy our clock icon and replace
the home icon with it
repeating this process for the rest of
our icon
once done we can discard the original
icons and give appropriate names to our
four new tabs
alright let's bring these icons to the
front and position them nicely on our
rectangle ensuring they're Centered for
symmetry
foreign
tastic moving on we'll create two
circles we'll place the first circle on
top of our rectangle setting Dimensions
at 80 by 80 pixels initially before
stretching the width to 110 pixels to
create a more ellipse-like shape
remember to align it precisely with our
first home icon that's key here let's
then adjust the fill to match the app's
background color
next we'll create a second Circle and
align it with the ellipse and the home
icon
we'll slightly lower our lips so its
middle aligns perfectly with the top of
the rectangle
and before we proceed we push our light
circles slightly down once done we'll
double click on the ellipse to grab the
anchor points we're going to grab the
left handle and pull it towards the
center of our Circle and we're doing the
same thing on the right side too
foreign
to the bottom handle this next step is
important in the right panel we'll
switch the option from no mirroring to
mirror angle and length this smart trick
ensures that if we adjust one side the
other side will mirror the change
perfectly maintaining asymmetrical look
once we're satisfied with the shape of
our hole we'll drag it a bit lower and
do the same with the circle
we'll fine-tune the bottom part just a
bit more
the following step involves cutting out
the unnecessary part of our hole we'll
create a rectangle to cover the top part
select everything and then we'll use
subtract selection to remove the excess
we'll then realign our white circle and
change the fill of our hole to match the
background color
foreign
ly let's give our bottom navigation a
nice radius for that smooth rounded look
amazing this looks lovely now it's time
to add those final touches to our
animated bottom navigation here's what
we'll do first let's change the color of
our circle to the lovely green shade
from our apps color selection
we'll bring our icons above the
rectangle and align them perfectly in
the middle
for our first icon home let's give it a
dark color from the app's color palette
position the icon precisely within the
green circle ensuring it's right in the
middle perfect we've tackled the most
crucial part and it only gets easier
from here now let's select everything
and create a frame this is an important
step to ensure that our design works
properly
foreign
after that let's create a new copy and
rename our frames accordingly
now we'll position the clock icon in the
exact horizontal position as the home
icon once that's done we'll move the
icon back to its original position
perfectly aligned with the rest of the
icons great now select both the circle
and the hole and move them below the
clock icon making sure they're aligned
perfectly with the icon itself next
change the color of the clock icon to
dark and the color of the home icon to
Gray
foreign
to make things easier and faster it's
best to create color styles for the dark
and gray colors this will come in handy
throughout the design process
fantastic progress now let's move on to
creating the third part it's a similar
process as before
place the next icon in the position of
the selected icon and then move the
clock icon back to its original state
drag the circle and hold below the icon
and align them with it change the colors
using our freshly created color Style
and there's one more step left
let's bring the profile icon to the same
level as the graph icon and then bring
the graph icon back to its original
position
now let's apply the color styles we
created to all our icons
perfect now here's where the magic
happens we'll turn each tab into a
separate component
select all four navigation tabs and then
select combine as variants this brings
everything into one component
now let's define the interactions
between these components
switch to the Prototype panel
in the first tab click on the clock icon
and connect it with the tab below it
Now define the interaction in the right
sidebar by choosing a trigger and action
in the animation section select smart
animate from the transition field apply
gentle easing to the transition and
change the duration to 1000 milliseconds
connect the third icon with the third
tab
in the fourth icon with the fourth tab
using the same animation parameters
we'll repeat a similar process for the
second tab connecting the first icon
with the first tab
the third icon with the third tab
and the fourth icon with the fourth tape
great now let's connect the last tab to
other tabs
perfect we now have everything connected
let's go back to the design panel and
change the white fill to match the
background color of our app
also make sure to match the color of our
hole with the background
foreign
excellent
now let's select this component either
from our panel or the assets panel and
position it nicely at the bottom of our
app screen
foreign
let's preview what we've created if
everything works as expected we should
see a smooth transition in the bottom
navigation
look at that
our beautiful animated bottom navigation
is now complete
feel free to preview it through a mobile
frame as well to see how it looks
if you like this video subscribe to our
channel to get notified when a new video
comes out see you in the next video
[Music]